welcome back to the true Jordy YouTube
channel today we are talking about the
shocking allegations directed at WWE
owner Vince mcmah and WWE legend Brock
Lesnar and ironically they've just
announced A5 billion deal with Netflix
the next Netflix crime documentary could
be this be perfect or is it even a crime
we're going to talk about the details
today cuz I think perception is
important with this sort of stuff
because Vince McMahon for decades play
play a horrible evil boss who would
manipulate his employees and force women
into compromising positions and throw
his way around they say wrestling's fake
I'm not really sure how fake it is
anymore but that was a character and we
do have to try and remove that from our
minds and just look at the facts for
what they are but there's two sides to
every story and we already know that you
know this is the allegations towards him
which are going to be as bad as possible
and then Vince's defense will try and
make them look as good as possible so
our job today is to look at the
allegations and think where the truth
might lie now what we do know is that
Vince is 78 years old and that the
accuser Janelle Grant is 44 years old or
43 depending on where you look on Google
and she is claiming that she has been a
victim of sex trafficking coercion
grooming and quite a lot of things now
the reason I bringing up our age is 44
you're a grown ass woman you could have
a 24y old daughter who's got a child and
one on the way you could have grandkids
yeah and you're old enough at 44 to
understand that decisions have
consequences and you are responsible for
those decisions now despite Vince
stepping down from the WWE and resigning
he is actually denying this I think him
having 11% ownership in the we means he
does not want to affect business by
having these rumors going around in this
lawsuit so he stepped down but his
lawyer has said that the lawsuit is full
of lies obscene madeup instances that
never occurred and a vindictive
Distortion of the truth he will
vigorously defend himself so let's look
at what Janelle is actually accusing
Vince of because apparently in 2019 in
Vince's building that he lives in the
penthouse apartment of this woman uh was
in that building living there and
struggling to get a job and Vince became
aware of that now keep in mind that this
woman had no corporate work experience
prior to meeting Vince and therefore
really Vince had no business offering
her a job of any sort whatsoever now
Vince did have meetings with this woman
several of them prior to them ever
working together where she claimed he
did a number of inappropriate things for
someone having you know a business
meeting such as turning up in his
underwear there's a red flag he was also
touching her legs asking for hugs and he
warned her to keep their closeness a
secret because these meetings weren't
being held in a [__] office where
everyone can see right it was very
private in I think a condo that he had
and this woman would have known full
well Vince mcmah is a married man and
has been for [__] 50 years or
something so this was all prior to her
taking any sort of job from Vince mcmah
now I don't know about you but when I go
for job interviews usually the Giza
oppositors they're not wearing their
boxer shorts and if that did happen to
me probably just probably not for me
this bit weird here is it so the red
flags were there that this wasn't that
kind of employment from get-go before
anything was agreed now Janelle said
she's struggling for money and Vince
proposed an agreement where she would
have employment in exchange for sex now
the employment ended up being about 200
Grand a year plus gifts which ended up
being in the tens and tens of thousands
of pounds as well on top of that now
Janelle said she had and I quote no
choice but to take the job 44 years old
could have worked your entire life to
build yourself a career in which you
were earning a good wage and didn't have
to take a role as a professional
prostitute at a company with Vince
McMahon but you apparently you've got no
choice in the matter how about don't
take the job wild idea Just Go With It
uh saying all thanks Vince not really
interested in 78 year olds mate I'll
catch you later but no uh she did take
the job despite claiming she felt
trapped it's weird I don't feel trapped
before I take a job I feel trapped when
I'm in the job sometimes but that's the
point where you've got the opportunity
to just walk out the way this is written
is if is if you put a [__] gun to our
head 200 Grand a year was not a gun to
your head yeah I think pretty woman got
$3,000 uh for like a a week that you
you've really come up trumps you like 44
as well you're not getting any younger
so and the way it's written in the
document that her lawyer is she
succumbed to the pressure the way this
is just so written so that she has
absolutely no responsibility for the
agreement that she agreed to is
mindblowing to me this is a
44y old woman and they're trying to make
it out like it's a sleazy boss who like
had a worker working under him from like
being an intern from like a teenager and
then 5 years in one day start putting
pressure onto her to give him sexual
favors in order to keep a job that I can
understand how you'd feel trapped in
that situation this is a 44y old woman
who on day one Vincent M goes want a
shers for money and she goes yeah right
then what we talking about here don't
get me wrong he's not a great person for
doing that I don't commend it but let's
have it right this is a grown ass woman
who is agreeing to have sex for money
lots of it and I'm not saying it didn't
go too far down the road or we're going
to look into that but right now as it
stands she knew what she was entering
into and the way it's worded here as if
she didn't have a clue it's ridiculous
and I'm not on Vince's side or anyone's
side but you've just got to make sense
and this ain't making sense here I
succumbed to the pressure I had no
choice [__] walk out the door you
can't be 44 acting like some little kid
wet behind the ears man he then makes a
[__] job up for her called
administrative coordinator where she's
basically coordinating the come out of
his balls and she admits she even
struggled to look busy in the office
because her co-workers were all so busy
and she was sat twiddling her [__]
thumbs so she was under No Illusion of
her purpose in this company at all from
get-go so let's look at the gift she got
on top of her 200 Grand a year
alternative Medical Care uh clubhouse
access to the horse racing and lovely
ladies day out WrestleMania private uh
Transportation premium tickets all of
the above two grand in a Nordstrom gift
card which is like dresses shoes jewelry
fill your boots love enjoy it's on me a
massive box of gadiva which apparently
is chocolates very Posh ones
$220,000 in surgery well if I'm going to
play with them every day they might as
well be bigger a pearl diamond necklace
um a whole bunch of Kashmir clothing
sunglasses um blanket a large bouquet of
flowers delivered every other week a
20122 brand new BMW a 5 grand gift
certificate for a spa day private Chef
Kate at dinners golden diamond necklaces
$155,000 worth of blooming Deale gift
cards took out of Saudi Arabia large BCA
flowers delivered every other week once
again just showered with gifts I'm going
to be real all of you women watching
this right now however few there are of
you God bless you thanks for the of view
you could never know what that's like
this is the elite level treatment yeah
now I'm just saying this all for context
because clearly she was getting a lot
out of the situation I'm not even sure
how you're allowed to receive those kind
of gifts through employment law anyway
but she's picking and choosing um you
know what rule she follows it seems and
in the document it says that Miss Grant
took her employment seriously how you're
just literally replying to Vince McMahon
all day with these sex texts when you
read these in Vince's uh voice it is
funnier why not let others see that
voluptuous body and what you shake
uncontrollably when you come now I know
how other people felt when they left at
me so basically he's just clearly making
a load of like fantasies up in his head
and trying to get hurt to play along
while he probably gets off on it maybe
I'll just line them up and have them
squir in your mouth all over your tit
and ass and taste everybody's come it's
that sort of wild [__] yeah this 78y old
man who's probably [__] half of the
WWE Divas in the past right it's going
to take a lot to get this whole [__]
off this one really does seem like
proper fantasy [__] so Vin says I've
just passed my phone around to a bunch
of guys on the tech crew they're looking
at pictures of you she's [__]
beautiful look at that ass I'd like to
get that I don't think he's really
passing his phone around I think that
he's making this up to make it out like
all these men are going to [__] her
could be wrong I paused to count how
many guys there were 12 and then I said
okay there's 12 of you and she would
love to [__] each and every one of you
it's just clearly fantasy talk this to
me oh you would say that wouldn't you
Jordy stop the comments I know they're
coming so is everyone else on here
apparently that's you Janelle you can't
get enough can you in the future it's
going to be so bad that you'll demand to
be [__] twice a day and not with
blacked out in a threeway that must be
someone else it certainly doesn't prove
that it wasn't consensual because
conveniently there are no replies from
her in which she is saying no I don't
want to do this so we have to take this
at face value yes Vince is dirty shock
despite This Woman's lack of actual
paperwork to do in her actual job she
would spend a lot of her days just
sending him nudes videos and that sort
of [__] and she said that she felt
compelled to because of his control over
her employment and that's what I kind of
have a problem with Y is like she's
framing it as if like out of the blue he
starts asking her for nudes when she was
just cracking on with our work no this
was the agreement from day one there was
no work to be done he wasn't dragging
you away from a deadline you had to make
there was no deadlines the only deadline
is I want to see a picture of your ass
on the table by the end of today and I'm
not saying that that makes Vince a good
person yeah he's shitty yeah it's a bit
creepy but you knew this convenient
Amnesia we're looking at here I get if
you'd been working there for 5 years and
out of the blue this happens that's very
inappropriate but this isn't that from
day one he said this is what I want from
you and you went yeah okay then I'll
take the money then the surprise man I
was just trying to get one with my job
and then this keeps asking for pictures
I'm just saying this ain't your classic
sleazy boss story when you agreed to be
sleazy together knowing he was a married
man now I'm supposed to feel sorry for
you you're 44 years old love you knew
fine well what the deal was now to be
fair as I said said earlier maybe it
went further than she was expecting and
I can accept that apparently she did
sustain injuries uh from uh having sex
with McMan I don't know if any of these
were proven if any of the scientific
evidence to this I haven't got a clue
maybe this is just her word against his
but apparently he did use sex toys on
her and the weird bit and it's hard not
to find this funny is he would name them
after WWE wrestlers that they thought
they resembled I don't know if he played
their entrance music as he got them out
of the [__] box or whatever well it's
the big show that would be a scary one
wouldn't it Jesus Christ you got to be
on your game the day love Lube up 7
foot2 the [__] God knows what the
dildo equivalent was I don't want to say
the rock either what other the wrestlers
made good dildos
hle [__] H now he'd be an easy day's
work he's a little one cuz he was a
little little fell Chris Beno would be a
killer bad choice of words Undertaker
all the lights go out comes out of a
coffin there's your dildo Janelle then
claims that Vince mcmah instructed her
to have one of several threesoms that
she would end up having and the first
time apparently she said no I don't want
to do it Vince then says well I want you
to do it because I love you she then
agrees now for the life of me whether or
not Vince did say he loved her or not
you've agreed it's consensual what
difference does it make if he said I
love you I I don't think it makes a
[__] blind bit of difference there
are men all over the world right now
saying that they love girls in order to
get them to sleep with them I don't know
if that's a crime it makes you a bit of
a [__] yeah no pun intended we'll
get to that I'm not evenin was a good
dude but I'm not sure what relevance
that this has this woman was a 44 year
old woman consenting and getting paid a
lot of money the threeome then happened
between her and him and a physical
therapist who Vince happened to be good
friends with I guess Vince is just
sitting chatting to this physical
therapist while he's [__] having work
done on him G yeah I've got this last
time do you want to shager with this do
you know like that's the kind of
scenario I'm getting here the physical
therapist is a bit weird all right then
bro it's Vince McMahon what the [__] are
you doing do you really want to say
78-year-old Vince mcmah naked I don't
care what the woman looks like no one
needs to say that the fact that he's
paying her so much to say that was for
good reason he's [__] minging I've
got no problem with her taking all that
money to look at someone that old nak
fair play you should be compensated it's
rank yeah this is where it gets a little
bit worse to be honest with you now she
does claim that during this apparently
Vince somehow managed to [__] on her
head and Vince then nipped off for a
shower while he instructed her to carry
on pleasuring the other dude with [__]
still in her hair he's 78 maybe he tried
to squeeze a thought out and it went
wrong while he was getting you know
pleasured off her or whatever it said as
if this was a thing I don't know if this
was a thing it might have just been an
accident at 78 I don't know how in
control of his bows He Is We just don't
know is the point but you think at that
point if you're a woman in that scenario
and you're getting paid this money
you're probably thinking at that point
like enough's enough yeah like cuz if
you're a conscious person and someone
shits on your head you usually leave do
you I don't know anyone that's happened
to but no she stayed now another man who
was involved in this is John laurenitis
who was an onscreen talent but also one
of the bosses at we a right-hand man so
to speak of Vince mcmah apparently him
and Vince Shaga in his office now she
has quoted them in this situation saying
that they said no means yes and take it
[__] um intimating that it wasn't
consensual may I remind you all that she
consistently agreed and turned up to all
of these sexual encounters and kept on
coming back for more her quoting them
saying this in without any proof
whatsoever by the way that they said
this doesn't prove anything like I'm
just being objective here it just gets
more and more weird the more I read this
stuff on top of that she also agreed to
start having sex with John laurenitis
individually so in the morning he'd wait
at a hotel tell she'd pop in they'd have
sex she'd then tell Vince about it so
that Vince could get off on it cuz she
knew that Vince would enjoy that and
look I'm not suggesting she enjoyed all
of this at all she might not have she
might have who knows I don't know and I
think it's easy reading this knowing
that none of us would want to be doing
that to think well that's not right she
shouldn't have to do that well yeah but
we're not in her life she chose to do
that and look I I just want to be clear
like I don't think any of this is good I
think this is gross disgusting but just
because I think it's gross and
disgusting does not mean that it should
be illegal for a woman who's 44 and
wants to go and do that to get paid
that's her decision but I think two
consenting adults should be able to
exchange money and do what the [__] they
want really I don't really care about
prostitution which is what this is and
this is where Brock Lesnar comes into it
now I'm a big Brock Lesnar fan right but
this just is a bit weird now because
Vince has instructed her to make sexual
pictures and videos to send Brock Lesnar
as a part of some sort of negotiation he
was having with Brock in order to get
him to resign with a w and it kind of
comes across as some weird sort of like
banter between Vince and Brock because
these are guys who've known each other
for decades and they're not normal
people and they're not behaving like
normal people at all here so Vince sends
these things to Brock as some sort of
offer of a a reward if he signs and
apparently he messages um her back Vince
and says Brock likes what he sees she
then claims that a sexual encounter was
set up between her and Brock I think in
the middle of some sort of business
meeting between Vince and and Brock but
apparently Brock got too drunk and
didn't show up to even think that that
happened it's just weird it gets even
weirder because Vince mcmah because
Brock didn't show up then went and gave
her a rough sex night where he role
played as Brock Lesnar I don't know if
he gave her the F5 finishing move or
what but apparently it was rough sex
that night and I'll repeat none of this
sounds nice but she was there doing it
by her own choice so apparently Vince
texts Janelle saying here's what he said
after I told him that the part of the
deal was [__] you Brock replied LOL
that's your Turf she will be ruined
after me and leave your ass plus after
me your tool won't fit anymore with a
bunch of laughing emojis where Brock
seemingly is sort of saying look that's
your chick and I not really into this
weird thing that you're into so
apparently Brock Lesnar messaged her
directly after that and asked for a
video of her pissing because apparently
that's what Brock leson has into and
apparently she did do it for him piss
and video it for Brock Lesnar yeah weird
and the way she's described it in the
document is unable to recognize herself
she did it meaning I don't know who I am
anymore this isn't really me but I did
it anyway you [__] 44 man a man's
asked you for a video of your pissing
and you've sent him a video of your
pissing even then just a little bit of
shred of acceptance that I am
responsible for anything I [__] do as
a grown ass woman is
nonexistent in this entire you haven't
shot anyone you've had a slash and
[__] recorded it and sent it to a
dirty man own it for Christ sakes and
she's dragging Brock Lesnar through the
dirt here do you know what I mean like
is there any need well there is isn't
there there is so this all happened
between about 2019 and 2022 when it was
around 2022 where Vince decided to break
it off Vince had said that his wife had
gotten word of the affair if you want to
even call it that because that would
even suggest that there was some form of
romance here which it doesn't really
feel like and that she needed to get the
[__] out of w and you know we'll we'll
break this off here and I'll make sure
that you're sweep financially from it
the reason she had to leave the we of
course was that she didn't even have a
real [__] job and that the only job
she was there for was to [__] Vince
mcmah so Vince offers her $1 million to
sign a NDA obviously to keep her mouth
Shir and sweep everything under the
carpet but she declined yeah funny all
thing she says I'm going to need 3
million due to loss of earning potential
despite the fact that when he met her
she didn't have two pennies to rub
together and couldn't get a job for love
no money not sure what earning potential
we're talking about there but yeah she
wanted 3 million quid and Vince accepted
that and it would basically be a 1
million upfront job with another you
know 500 Grand I think every 6 months up
until the 3 million was paid off now as
part of the chat at the time he did
actually instruct that to keep on you
know appeasing Brock Lesnar if he uh
messaged her I don't know if that really
happened or if Brock Lesnar was just
messaging her and she wanted to try a
look with him and get some cash out of
him but she carried on messaging Brock
Lesnar she sent him more photographs
Brock apparently was going to fly in and
and [__] out at one point the weather
was bad he didn't fly in that never
happened that was where Brock Lesnar
checks out with this story and since
then Brock Lesnar was pulled from last
weekend's Royal Rumble that he was
scheduled to appear in so it remains to
be seen what's going to happen to Brock
in this but he's definitely not come out
smelling the Roses although he probably
smells better than she did during that
threesome after the initial $1 million
payment was made and the further
payments were scheduled to be made the
leak about Vince McMahon's several n
that he' had signed by multiple women I
think who worked at the we at one point
or another got out and Vince did not pay
the remaining money that she was owed as
part of her NDA she only got the 1
million still a lot of [__] money
like but that probably is part of the
reason why we're now getting this
fulllength lawsuit from her and she is
claiming that she is so traumatized and
and so unable to function now because of
what she's been put through she can no
longer work again so therefore she's
going to need a fuckload of money from
Vince mcmah to make sure she's
comfortable for the rest of our life
who's seen that coming now I know a lot
of what we've just read is going to be
the absolute worst possible scenario put
across by her lawyers to make Vince look
as bad as possible Vince's lawyers will
then do the exact opposite and try and
make him look as good as possible and
the truth is somewhere in the middle
however when I look at this even still
without Vince's side of the story it
looks like a very straightforward
situation where someone will paid money
for sex knew fine well what they were
getting themselves involved in they
didn't quite get as much money as they
hoped for and now they're using a
lawsuit to try and get more money as as
as much money as possible but do I buy
into the idea that she was some innocent
little victim who had no idea what she
was doing here that like the way they
put it across absolutely not you knew
fine well what you were doing as did he
Triple H has since responded he is now
sort of the acting face and leader of
the we now that Vince mcmah is no longer
there did read the lawsuit that came out
this week and if you did what was your
reaction to it I did not I did not um
that's his father-in-law and the
Granddad to his children and there's a
lawsuit where this man has been removed
from the company and you're claiming you
haven't bothered to read the lawsuit
I've read the lawsuit Bro you've been
spending Christmas with this [__] for
the last 30 [__] years I'm pretty
sure he's read the lawsuit I'll go back
to what I said before it
this this an amazing week for us not
really is it to have the founding member
of the we have this lawsuit come out it
isn't amazing if you win the lottery and
a family member dies you still can't
call it amazing we're at the most
exciting point to me business wise I
think I understand that you can't always
tackle things head on when you're a
leader of an organization you've got to
sort of play clever you can't call it
exciting that's not the words to use you
you can deflect by allans means don't
don't do that though so yeah I'm not
sure how he handled that the best so to
wrap this up I am in no way condoning
anything Vince mcmah has done I don't
think any of it is okay morally I think
obviously is a piece of crap really
let's be honest but this woman is 44 and
she is refusing to accept a shred of
responsibility for her actions when she
clearly knew what she was getting
herself into and agreed to all of it and
we still haven't heard Vince's side of
the story either so I think that this is
far from just a case of He's the bad guy
she's the the victim and that's it
opening I don't think it's as simple as
that anyway let me know what you thought
of this in the comments below and how
you view this case don't forget if you
haven't already subscribe to the true
Jordy YouTube channel hit that like
button thanks for watching and I'll see
you on the next
one